this video is sponsored by brilliant
Egypt's Old Kingdom was the age of
pyramids the first flourishing of
civilization along the River Nile
lasting for approximately half a
millennium from 2700 to 2200 BC with God
Kings constructing funeral monuments
that last to this day the lifeblood of
the kingdom was the Nile every year it
would flood and inundate the floodplain
allowing for the planting of crops by
Farmers but those floods weren't
consistent they would vary year to year
and a weak flood meant little planting
was possible and if food wasn't
stockpiled by local rulers the nomarks
that meant almost certain starvation
normally these weak floods would occur
once every five years or so allowing
them to be somewhat managed but around
2200 BC the Old Kingdom was hit by weak
flood after weak flood drought after
drought famine after famine and combined
with the ineffectual leadership of the
old Pharaoh Pepe II the kingdom
disintegrated into local rule by the
nomarks while societal collapse
generally has more than one clear-cut
cores scientists think that at least a
major contributing factor to the
eventual downfall of the Old Kingdom and
several other Kingdoms at the same time
more on that in a bit was a persistent
change in the weather in the Watershed
of the Nile but what caused those
changes well we think we know the ocean
but amazingly the ocean on the other
side of the planet the weather at a
given location seems to vary day to day
almost randomly but there are patterns
between locations so more obviously if
the weather here is warm and dry for
example then it's likely also warm and
dry here and there are also very
predictable patterns in time if the
weather is warm now then in six months
time it will probably be cold because of
the annual cycle there are also however
patterns that connect both spatial and
temporal changes patterns of the weather
changing over large areas over time what
we call a teller connection now the most
easy to understand are these is probably
the Arctic oscillation sometimes called
the North Atlantic oscillation that
there is definitely a difference simply
put if the pressure here is higher than
normal higher relative to a long-term
average then the pressure here is
probably lower than normal and vice
versa it's a hemispheric seesaw of mass
in the atmosphere with the Arctic
oscillation index a number telling you
if air has sloshed towards the pole or
away from it with that change taking
place over a few months while this
specific formulation of the Arctic
oscillation is actually very new dates
back to just 1998. there is some
evidence as a historical aside that the
Vikings understood some impact of the
Arctic oscillation in the Atlantic a
thousand years ago and they noticed it
because the impacts are huge and they
range across the entire Northern
Hemisphere changes in the Arctic
oscillation impact the weather directly
through changes in surface air pressure
which we can see clearly on a map this
is the average change in pressure seen
during a positive Arctic oscillation
index but there are also indirect impact
in changing weather patterns both
temperature and precipitation are
changed across the Northern Hemisphere
by the value of the AO index via changes
in surface pressure perhaps most clearly
the value of the AO index changes how
storms cross the Atlantic if the
pressure over Iceland is relatively High
while the pressure over the Azores is
relatively low then storms are more
likely to track further south and if
those pressure anomalies are reversed
then they're more likely to track
further north there they are they're
listing lazily to the left it's worth
noting that the Arctic oscillation
doesn't exist in isolation just as any
signal can be broken down into sine
waves of different frequencies and
amplitudes in a Fourier decomposition
the weather at a given location can be
broken down into the influence of many
different factors the Arctic oscillation
is one of them and in some cases will be
a very important one but it's not the
whole story local geography changes in
land use a warming Trend and other
teleconnections will all play a role in
constructing a weather signal Egypt's
Old Kingdom is believed to have fallen
at the hand of one of those other
teleconnections one that dwarfs the
Arctic oscillation in its impacts
perhaps the single most important
mechanism of internal climate
variability on Earth the Conqueror of
the Old Kingdom wasn't a regional ruler
but enso the El Nino Southern
oscillation this teleconnection crops up
everywhere it's been shown to have an
effect on areas as diverse as Antarctic
Ice formation the Indian Monsoon
hurricane activity in America Coral
bleaching and agricultural yields in
Africa sound familiar unlike the Arctic
oscillation the El Nino Southern
oscillation isn't just about masks
sloshing around the atmosphere it's an
interplay of the atmosphere and the
ocean it's a duet on a planetary scale
here's how it works there's a huge
overturning circulation of air that
reaches across the Pacific called The
Walker circulation named after Gilbert
Boomerang Walker who identified it
around the town of the 20th century he
was nicknamed Boomerang because he was
obsessed with them when he was an
undergrad at Cambridge though funnily
enough when you do study this stuff his
name just keeps appearing just keeps
coming back air moves from east to west
across the ocean before rising and
returning this is driven by a difference
in surface pressure between the East and
West Pacific which varies year to year
if the pressure difference is Big then
the circulation is strong if it's small
the circulation is weak so where does
the ocean come into this well the
pressure difference is driven by the
temperature difference between the
Western and Eastern Pacific Ocean and
here's where it gets really interesting
because the Walker circulation doesn't
just move air across the Pacific it also
induces a great ocean current of water
water that leaves the coast of South
America moving westwards and needs to be
replaced which it is by cold deep water
upwelling from below which changes the
temperature of the Eastern ocean and so
the pressure difference and so the
strength of the circulation the ocean
forces the atmosphere and the atmosphere
forces the ocean and the interplay
between the two can result in huge
changes for both on the scale of months
and years in particular there are two
extreme states of the system that we
refer to as El Nino and La Nina in El
Nino conditions The Walker circulation
weakens or even reverses and so less
water is transported across the ocean
and less is drawn from the depths off
the coast of South America meaning the
water there is warmer than normal in La
Nina conditions the opposite is true The
Walker circulation is stronger than
normal which means more water is
transported across the ocean more water
upwells and so the coast of South
America is colder we describe which
state the system is in using some form
of enso index a number the sign of which
tells us if the system is in El Nino or
La Nina conditions and the magnitude of
which tells us how extreme the state is
the changes in sea surface temperature
and the winds will obviously have an
impact on the local environment of the
Pacific but by Merit being such a vast
system Research indicates that the state
of the system impacts weather across the
world by combing through global data
sets and analyzing how they change in
the aftermath of a change of the enso
index scientists have constructed maps
of how enso forces precipitation surface
pressure and temperature around the
world to put it simply changes in the
sea surface temperature of the west
coast of South America via the Walker
circulation in the Pacific change
weather across the planet in a huge
teleconnection this like all
teleconnections is an example of
internal natural variability in the
earth's climate the plan is probably
been doing this for as long as there's
been a Pacific Ocean biological evidence
indicates that it's been happening for
at least several thousand years so given
the significant impacts that enso has on
whether now and are pretty good
knowledge of where those impacts take
place it's not unreasonable to ask could
enso have been responsible for previous
disastrous changes in the weather wait a
minute does anyone hear hooves
must be zebras well it would be cool to
identify some complex part of the
earth's climate as being responsible for
the downfall of an Empire we have to
accept that the truth is quite possibly
more mundane that being said there is
evidence that past changes in the El
Nino Southern oscillation have changed
human history one example of which is
possibly the downfall of the Old Kingdom
in Egypt because Boomerang Walker didn't
just identify the southern oscillation
he also studied its impact on the Indian
Ocean he realized that depending on the
phase of the oscillation my mania or El
Nino the huge band of rain that forms in
the Indian Ocean every year the monsoon
was shifted specifically during El Nino
years with a weaker Walker circulation
less moisture is transported across the
Pacific that means there's less moisture
available for rain in the Indian Ocean
so on the western end of the Indian
Monsoon the Ethiopian Highlands receive
significantly less rainfall and as those
Highlands Supply between 60 and 70 of
the Niles Water that significantly
impacts the flooding of the Nile
Downstream in Egypt and do we have
evidence that this happened consistently
around 2200 BC and the fall of the Old
Kingdom
yeah it's worth noting that not everyone
agrees with this assessment that enso or
even necessarily a drought was
responsible for the fall of the Old
Kingdom this is archeology and very old
archeology so we're limited by what
evidence what data we have but there is
evidence via proxies of past climate
that around 4 200 years ago several
societies collapsed at about the same
time including the Old Kingdom in Egypt
the Acadian Empire Mesopotamia and the
Indus Valley Civilization in India this
would point to a shift in Regional
climate consistent with the impacts of a
strong persistent El Nino phase of Enzo
though again not everyone agrees that
these events were contemporaneous or
connected damn used so much of time and
your destruction of evidence however we
have more concrete evidence that other
societies were challenged and found
wanting By changes in enso in South
America as Brian Fagan writes in floods
famines and Emperors the great monche
civilization of modern-day Peru
flourished between the second and 9th
centuries A.D but was brought Crashing
Down by periods of intense drought
followed by catastrophic floods when
enso flipped from El Nino to La Nina
conditions local rulers were unable to
adapt to these changes and the society
fell apart similarly the Maya of
misoamerica suffered a major political
collapse and the end of the classic
period around 900 A.D quite what caused
this is the subject of huge debate but
there is plentiful evidence that
prolonged droughts occurred at the time
of the collapse which would have been a
catastrophe for farming and so have led
to instability those droughts may have
been caused by persistent El Nino
conditions or have been part of some
broader swing in Regional climate what's
clear is that localized changes in the
climate particularly persistent droughts
such as those caused by changes in the
enso index have historically been
devastating Fagan writes that
fluctuations in climate present a severe
and sometimes the ultimate test of a
civilization paleoclimatologists have
identified many natural cycles that
impact climate and thus life on this
planet and so is perhaps the most
important one on short time scales but
we know there are other longer time
scale cycles that take place over tens
or hundreds of thousands of years such
as chromalankovic cycles that can
completely reshape our planet these
natural shifts in climate have changed
even history bringing down Empires and
altering our Evolution guiding our
development as a civilization and our
response to past changes in climate
provide an idea of what challenges we
face in the future and how to overcome
them because we're currently facing a
changing climate much like the Old
Kingdom and the mache and the Maya did
the key difference of course being that
this is a type of change that's utterly
unprecedented in its rapidity and its
global scale and the fact that it's been
caused by
thus natural variability both internal
and external will continue this century
and beyond we're still going to face the
same challenges as civilizations of old
such as large changes in the El Nino
Southern oscillation index but we've
added a new layer of challenge there's
more energy trapped in the system now
that means higher temperatures more
extreme conditions the past teaches us
that there are two options for a
civilization that wants to survive a
change in the environment you either
innovate you adapt to your new
environment or you move elsewhere but if
you're talking about the climate of an
entire planet
that second option isn't really an
option the fall of the Old Kingdom the
Maya and the moche among many other
civilizations teach us that pretending
nothing is happening isn't a viable
strategy for survival when faced with a
change in the environment and what's
more we unlike they have caused our
Global shift in the climate and so have
the power to moderate how severe an
environmental shift we will have to face
doing nothing is not a strategy we need
to adapt and innovate but we also need
to stop making the problem worse
otherwise we can look to history to see
what may happen what's past is precedent
and possibly
prologue Boomerang Walker was a
brilliant mathematician actually
graduating as a senior Wrangler from
Cambridge meaning that he was the number
one math student that year and
specifically he became a statistician he
used his understanding of Statistics to
identify the huge Southern oscillation
part of enso something that would have
been impossible without his grounding in
Concepts like regression and the
chi-squared test but what are those and
how can you use them in your studies or
work well you can learn about those
concepts with brilliant who have kindly
sponsored this video brilliant is a
highly visual interactive website and
app that breaks down big Concepts into
understandable Parts they have thousands
of lessons across maths science and
computer science covering everything
from neural networks to statistics
including those techniques used by
Gilbert Walker all featuring gorgeous
interactive exercises with brilliant you
can skill up in just 15 minutes a day
with bite-sized lessons perfect if
you're trying to pick up a new skill in
a low pressure environment brush up on
old knowledge or supplement your
learning in the classroom for those
aiming for a career in stem or those who
want to stay sharp during their stem
career brilliant is an excellent
investment you can check out parts of
brilliant for free so there's no excuse
to it not at least have a look but to
get yourself a premium subscription and
access to all their courses you should
head to brilliant.org Simon Clark and
the first 200 people to do so will get a
20 discount that's brilliant.org Simon
Clark with thanks to brilliant for
sponsoring this video
I don't know about you but I find the
history of Science and perhaps the
history of atmospheric science
so this video was largely based on the
book floods famines and Emperors by
fagin as I mentioned before so if you
found this interesting you should go and
check this out you can also of course
check out firmament my book which is
about the development of atmospheric
science how we know what we know and
this is now out in North America as of
this week if you're in North America you
can finally get one like this look
physical you can touch it I really hope
you enjoyed this one if you did please
do pop the video a like if you'd like to
watch some more stuff from me then
here's some recommended viewing and that
just leads me to say thank you so much
again for watching I'll see you in the
next one